hi i'm eric boss in game of thrones
final season as an official trailer
battles dragons uncomfortable
realizations of incest damn i have
missed talking about this show
and now we finally have footage that's
longer than three or five seconds to
break down one minute 53 seconds at 24
frames per second that's like 27 billion
frames to break down hey i'm not good at
math there are missable details
all over the shots all pointing to clues
for how this epic game of thrones story
could
end so let us dig through it all frame
by frame and spoiler warning in case any
of this speculation ends up being too
accurate and ruins your life okay let's
get started
i know death
he's got many faces okay we opened on
arya stark scared alone in the darkness
her face covered in sweat and blood from
a nasty wound on her forehead
she appears to be running from someone
or from something
and she looks way more scared than we've
seen her in recent seasons
at least now that she's become a master
assassin but who or what is she running
from
much of this trailer's footage appears
to come from the epic battle of
winterfell that's supposed to happen in
episode three of this final season
and here arya could be fleeing a white
walker or a white
a resurrected corpse after they had
breached the walls of winterfell
now arya could be setting the trap you
know pretending to flee
but really luring this pursuer to a
place that she could more easily kill
them
just like she did with that pesky waif
and braavos in season six
but i don't know that fear looks pretty
sincere she doesn't look like she's
performing
so in case it's not a trap let's
consider other options notice how she's
clutching that dragonglass dagger that
she equips herself
in the later clip and she still has the
valyrian steel cat's paw dagger on her
side
so she is armed with two ways to kill a
white walker so maybe she just chokes
when she finally sees one in the flesh
or in the dead flesh
or maybe this particular white is a
corpse that freaked her out for another
big reason
like it's the corpse of a dead family
member
superfans and readers of the books know
that the show seems to have moved on
from introducing the character lady
stoneheart from the books as a character
on the show
but maybe catelyn stark's resurrected
corpse could be the thing arya is so
afraid to attack here
or for that matter a headless ned stark
skeleton a headless robb's dark corpse
the corpses of rickon or aunt liana
there's a lot of spooky old starks that
are buried there still
i think this is a look of fear only a
mother could inspire like
oh god i left the porn tab open on the
family computer another theory is that
arya could be running from the faceless
men who might have hunted her down to
winterfell
which could be why we hear arya talking
about her time worshiping the miniface
god in this clip i guess that's also the
look of fear only a runaway cult member
could have
can we let go of the blood out policy
fellas i have another theory for where
arya could be and who she's running from
and i'll get to it later but also in
this clip we see
sir davos seaworth walking the
battlements of the winterfell castle as
archers prepare this all reminds me a
lot of the moments leading up to the
battle of helm's deep and the lord of
the rings the two towers
and that is by design this episode is
being directed by the great miguel
sapochnick who directed the battle the
bastards in the heart home episode he's
really the best
and he set out to make a battle sequence
like what helm's deep was to the lord of
the rings
a nasty nighttime brawl but he wanted to
make his even longer and more complex
in interviews cast and crew so that they
built out the whole outdoor winterfell
set
so that supporting it could shoot all of
this action practically
without using too much green screen or
visual effects it was a grueling
production that lasted 11 weeks of night
shoots which the crew nicknamed
the long night after the fictional
winter in the game of thrones backstory
that spans several generations and looks
like
it might be happening again in this clip
we also see varys huddled with the women
and children in the winterfell crips
behind him i think you could see gilly
with her son
young sam and that might be sansa behind
them as well now this is interesting for
a few reasons
one remember john suggested in the past
that he would send
everyone to fight the army of the dead
including women children
and yeah probably eunuchs instead these
more vulnerable people are
waiting out the battles similar to when
sansa and cersei stowed themselves in
maegor's hold fast during the battle of
blackwater it's also something that we
saw the women and children do in the
battle of helm's deep i'm curious to
know what kind of stories or
jokes or motivational speeches varus
will tell these others to keep their
minds off the battle upstairs but we
should also remind ourselves that
gilly's baby was fathered by craster
and was therefore promised to the white
walkers presumably to be converted to a
young new member of their white walker
race remember the white walkers came
after sam and gilly for this baby before
and if they breach these crips or if the
dead stark ancestors rise out of their
tombs as whites this baby is going to
become a real hot potato before i move
on arya's voiceover is interesting she
brags that she knows death saying he's
got many faces suggesting that this
night king
is just one of many faces of the
miniface god aka death whom she
worshipped as part of the faceless men
and now she seeks to fight the god whom
she once worshipped in the entertainment
weekly article that preceded this
trailer release one of the accompanying
photos included this shot of the night
king look closely at those eyes
the pupils are in the shape of seven
pointed stars
of course the symbol of the faith of the
seven the new gods so the fact that this
is on the night king
someone who's been more associated with
the old gods of the north this could be
another clue that all of the religions
of westeros and essos
these new gods the old gods of the north
the lord of light of essos the
many-faced god the drowned god from the
iron islands
are all different interpretations of
these same natural phenomena and myths
kind of like how our real world
religions have their own takes on
devastating floods and game changing
messiahs or you know maybe this
entertainment weekly was just a
photoshopped promo image and the night's
king eyes don't normally look like that
which is
entirely plausible let's move on
i look forward to seeing this one
everything you did brought you where you
are now
okay once again arya runs for her life
we hear this sound
it sounds like the snarl of white walker
i like that one who attacks sam and
gilly
but look closely at the shot of arya
there is definitely a shadow of someone
chasing after her
it's hard to tell though it does look
lower than her like maybe someone
shorter than her or someone coming
upstairs or maybe it's just the angle of
the light casting a lower shadow on the
wall but then we move on to a braver
aria before she wets herself in that
whole scramble
arming herself with this dragonglass
dagger in addition to her
change demeanor she's also wearing this
cape in the shot
which she no longer has when she was
running this also ties into my other
theory for
whom arya could be running from we'll
get to that later but next we see the
iron fleet of euron greyjoy with his
black sails and kraken sigil
at the end of season seven cersei said
that she sent euron to retrieve the
golden company of essos
and bring them back to westeros and that
appears to be whom we see
in the next shot on board euron's
flagship the silence
this figure with the blonde hair could
be harry strickland leader the golden
company perhaps played by mark grissman
the golden company is an army of
sellswords founded by supporters of
house blackfyre
of damon blackfire bastard son of king
aegon iv targaryen who legitimized damon
and kicked off the whole blackfyre
rebellion which is actually a series of
rebellions among sex of the targaryen
family it all took place a hundred years
before the main events of game of
thrones anyway after this failed
rebellion the soldiers fled to the free
cities of essos and founded this elite
mercenary company of over 10 000
infantry
and war elephants the thing about them
is they never break their contracts
their motto is
our word is as good as gold and remember
cersei took out a loan from the iron
bank to pay for the golden company to
help her defeat daenerys army
essentially going behind danny's back
after danny's plea to cersei to join
their cause against the threat from the
north and next this is exciting
tormund giant spain and beric dondarrion
with his flaming sword confirmed to
still be alive after the night king's
attack on the wall at eastwatch by the
sea
thank god they now join dolores ed
currently commander of the night's watch
or at least whatever's left of it
i just love that these three are
together considering they're vastly
different backgrounds
a wildland rogue religious nut from the
stormlands
and the goth so i'm guessing tormund and
berg ran down the wall westward to meet
ed and castle black and next we see
bran and sam perhaps discussing which
one of them will break that awkward news
to jon that he's been sleeping with his
aunt or maybe this is during the battle
of winterfell and sam could be
tasked with protecting bran let's move
[Music]
on
they're coming okay next is a shot of
king's landing with cersei smiling as
she looks out flanked by her hand
qyburn and commander of the queen's
guard gregor clegane the mountain
perhaps she's smiling because she sees
the iron fleet arriving with her golden
company
cersei now wears this new shoulder armor
with chains
perhaps to reflect her refusal to
surrender in the war for the iron throne
against danny's forces
next there's a shot of this boy watching
the unsullied marching through
winter town on the way to winterfell
wintertown is a small town on the
outskirts of the castle walls
contains that brothel that terry met
rosin and that place where brienne
stayed in to keep watch on satsa while
listening to sting and the police on
repeat and for those asking
no i don't think this boy is the love
child of john and danny in the distant
future keep in mind this is the
unsullied first
arrival at winterfell don't even know if
dany's pregnant just you know stop
wanting children from incest to happen
please during this arrival we see john
and danny marching with the unsullied
side by side
neither of them leading the other and
this is an important approach
because i'm sure john doesn't want these
northerners to think he's already given
in to this targaryen invader but rather
according to optics at least they're on
the same side of the greater conflict
and sansa marvels are the site of
daenerys dragons soaring overhead
there's drogon and rhaegal and for once
the colors are actually vibrant in their
wings the red and black and drogon the
green and bronze of rhaegal i gotta say
the imagery of dragons over winterfell
is striking actually reminds me of that
passage in a clash of kings in which
bran envisioned through the eyes of his
direwolf summer a great winged
snake that breathed fire flying over the
ashes of winterfell as it burned down
and that led to a popular fan theory
that
there could be a dragon egg buried in
the crypts beneath winterfell
the idea being that all targaryen babies
are given a dragon egg as a gift
and john aka aegon could have an egg
egg's egg
and that it could have been buried by
ned alongside the remains of lyanna
stark in order to hide the truth about
her marriage to rhaegar and the truth
about jon's true lineage
i don't know if that's true but i do
like this whole image of ice cracking
open the tombs of old starks
to fight alongside the dead but at the
same time fire cracking open the egg of
old targaryens to fight alongside the
living
next clip our enemy doesn't tire
[Music]
doesn't stop doesn't feel
okay here we see danny joining john down
the crips of winterfell
it sounds like this first episode of
season eight will feature a number of
parallels and callbacks to the pilot of
the series with john and danny's arrival
in winterfell mirroring robert's arrival
in greeting in winterfell in the first
episode so i imagine this scene will be
a callback to the moment that ned and
robert visited the grave of lyanna stark
maybe john is visiting this grave now
after
learning from bran or sam that this is
actually his mother now to be clear i'm
not sure if this is her grave because if
you look at that old grave statue behind
them
statues holding its sword by the hilt as
opposed to the statues in the
backgrounds of past shots of leona's
grave which held the swords lower on the
blade part but speaking of swords we see
the blacksmiths hard at work in
winterfell
forging new weapons probably from
dragonglass in order to fight the white
walkers
leading them is gendry sorry ladies a
bit too cold for him to go shirtless i
guess we also see
sir jorah mormont lining up outside the
walls of winterfell with some dothraki
galloping past behind him but something
interesting to point out about jorah
here notice what he's armed with on the
left hanging down from the side of the
horse you can see
one weapon maybe that's his anointed
knight sword which would be on his right
since he's right-handed but look in the
other side
that pommel and crossguard look a lot
like heartspain the valerian steel
family sword of house tarly
stolen by sam in season six jorah
already refused to take back longclaw
his family valyrian steel sword given to
jon by
jorah's father jior so maybe sam wants
this priceless valyrian steel sword
in the most able hands to defend against
the white walkers
jon has longclaw jaime has widow's whale
brienne has oath keeper
arya has the cat's paw dagger so maybe
the next best swordsman would probably
be ser jorah we also see a shot of grey
worm and missandei
embracing as he marches off to battle
and then a shot of this
figure fighting alongside the fire lit
and battlements it's a bit hard to tell
but notice how the figure cuts
through the other and that other thing
begins to disintegrate
much like the way white walkers
disintegrate when you swing valerian
steel through them
that plus the haircut of this figure
makes me pretty sure this is brienne and
then right after this we see jaime
lannister
also partaking in this battle now we
weren't sure if jaime was going to make
good on his promise to join the others
in winterfell but i love that his
journey has brought him back to the
place where he was once
such a smug piece of [ __ ] it sounds like
he's yelling pull
here like he's commanding archers to
release their arrows or maybe operators
of a catapult or trebuchet to release
it's also interesting to see that jaime
and brienne could be fighting alongside
each other in this battle because in a
storm of swords jaime experienced that
whole
fever dream while he was sitting on the
weirwood stump in which he perceives
all kinds of strange potentially
prophetic visions and in one of them he
fought alongside brienne
with both of them carrying swords of
light and flame
some of theorized that the prophecy of
azor ahai
and the flaming sword lightbringer could
actually be the twin valyrian steel
swords of oath keeper and widow's whale
which were both forged from the sword
ice and
these two destined lovers must reunite
themselves and their swords to vanquish
the white walkers
oh the show probably won't go that deep
in the mythology but it's another
adorable thing to think about but let's
move on
[Music]
i promise to fight for the living
okay in this section we see the red keep
with cersei on the iron throne and
qyburn and the mountain and the queen's
guard around her basin there are two
others one of them could be the golden
company leader and the other
perhaps tycho nestoris mark gaddis's
character
representative the iron banks lent
cersei the money to pay for the golden
company but then next cersei appears as
some different scene dressed down an
odd mix of emotions on her face and she
sips wine
now this should raise some red flags
because remember cersei's supposed to be
pregnant at least that's what she told
jamie last season
drinking isn't supposed to be good for
the baby so
maybe this means she had a miscarriage
which would adhere to that philosophy
told to her by the woodswitch maggie the
frog in the books that she would bear no
more than three children who would die
or
cersei could have been lying about her
pregnancy or maybe she is pregnant
she hasn't lost a baby and it's just one
glass of wine it's also possible that
this
is a shot of cersei at the end of her
rope and she's actually swallowing
poison it could be a kind of replay of
the moment that she almost poisoned
tommen and herself
during the battle of blackwater next
there's this shot of the two dragons
soaring over this beautiful frozen
landscape
and this shot of arya gazing up in shock
that we saw in the recent hbo promo
philip mullin actually did a pretty
comprehensive breakdown of these few
seconds
and what they could mean for arya's
destiny make sure to go check out that
video
and then after a quick shots of gray
worm putting on his unsullied helmet
followed this shot of jon in the
godswood of winterfell
we move on i intend to keep that promise
[Applause]
[Music]
okay here there's a quick shot of the
hound sander clegane
facing away from the flames because
remember he hates fire
fire bad but considering fire is one of
the only ways to kill whites the
battle of winterfell is gonna really
suck for him the entertainment weekly
article that came out actually included
a promo photo of the hound crossing
swords with the mountain
perhaps as a tease for the clegane bowl
that we've all been dying to happen
or maybe it's just a publicity thing and
jaime explains his intention to keep his
promise to fight for the living and this
location does look like a room in
winterfell kind of like the room that
daenerys appears to be in later in the
trailer assuming that jamie is back in
winterfell it's just gonna be a very
awkward reunion between him and bran who
probably doesn't need to be the
three-eyed raven to remember getting
pushed out of a tower
but who knows maybe mr robot will let
bygones be bygones and see a bigger role
for jaime in this war to come
and forgive the king slayer for his
misdeeds in fact remember that line from
bran earlier
everything you did brought you where you
are now where you belong
now i'm assuming that brand's probably
saying this to jon snow
referring to his true identity as aegon
targaryen and his whole destiny and
hero's journey throughout the show but
maybe bran is
actually saying these words to jamie
lannister who has also made very
surprising choices over the course of
this journey and it's led him on a very
odd and surprising path
and since jaime has really been a
wanderer maybe his true home is
winterfell but next there's a very quick
shot of a hand curling around a spear
you can see torch flames flickering
looks a lot like the lighting of the red
keep in king's landing and actually that
cuff
flap over the hand looks a lot like the
sleeve of the hand of the golden company
leader so this could be him prepping for
battle in the red keep but others have
said that his hand looks more
slender suggesting this could be someone
like arya and maybe this leads to her
whole
water dancing twirls that she does in
the other shot and that arya could be in
king's landing if that is true that
finally brings me to the other theory
for what arya could be running from in
those opening shots one of the reasons
she's no longer wearing her cape
is that this setting is a bit warmer and
that we're actually seeing her in the
middle of an assassin mission
in the red keep remember at the top of
arya's list is still
cersei and maybe if cersei is drinking
poison in that one shot
maybe she's being forced to drink the
poison by arya the way jaime forced
lady olenna to drink poison when
highgarden fell it rhymes just like
poetry and maybe arya's running from the
mountain
or other members of the queen's guard or
from euron greyjoy from someone in the
golden company from a war elephant
probably not but she's also got that
blood on her face maybe that blood is
someone else's
maybe it could come from a skin mask
that she wore to sneak into the red keep
all stuff to think about but next
there's the shot of jon
charging in the battle probably
wondering how many times in his life
he's gonna have to get all bloody and
muddy outside winterfell and some
soldiers rushing the gates and then some
quick shots of horses plowing through
the snow
if you look real closely at some of
these frames you can almost make out
what kind of looks like
shaggy or white or gray fur maybe among
these horses
are dire wolves we haven't seen ghosts
in this trailer or like ever
it could also be nymeria coming back
leading her pack of wolves rushing into
this battle to help
a nerd can dream then we see daenerys
and john walking up to drogon and
rhaegal as a feast
you can see the melted ring in the snow
for when they charred their kill with
dragonfire before eating them i think
we're all hoping that this is leading up
to a moment which danny mounts drogon
and john mounts rhaegal whom remember
was named after jon's biological father
rhaegar targaryen there's a quick shot
of sansa doing some dramatic blinking
and then arya doing some badass moves
twirling a spear
perhaps using some of the moves that she
learned from the waif but this is
interesting notice how whatever she
kills
seems to release a lot of blood
definitely more blood than you would
expect from a white which is a rotting
corpse one theory that i really like is
that we could be looking
at giant spiders or at least giant the
size of hounds honestly any spider
bigger than a fingernail is giant
remember the army of the dead
is rumored to have giant spiders you
might remember that terrifying old man
ghost story they swept through cities
and kingdoms
riding their dead horses hunting with
their packs of pale
spiders biggest hounds lady you're
scaring us
yeah nan's story is even scarier than
the real thing anyway maybe all this
blood is coming
from one of these giant terrifying
spiders but next there's a shot of danny
looking
pretty bummed out this is either the
face of someone learning they've been
boat sexing their nephew
or even worse that she made a baby with
said nephew and after some quick shots
of tyrion
and drogon blowing fire in our faces
rude we move on to the last clip
okay here the unsullied are lining up
outside winterfell again looking very
helms deepy behind them and the darkness
are some kind of wooden machinery maybe
catapults or trebuchets and joining the
ranks are brienne and podrick and notice
the soldiers behind them
they're holding shields bearing the
white crescent moon and falcon of house
aaron
making these knights of the veil these
poor suckers are getting dragged in all
kinds of fights they probably don't care
about now some have said that if you
look at their breastplates it kind of
looks like they're stamped with a new
sigil
it's a combination of the stark direwolf
and the targaryen dragon
but that could just be from a
description of some props that someone
saw on set a little tough for me to make
it out here i don't know why the knights
of the veil would be wearing so many
different sigils and sir jorah sizes up
the coming threat
undead centaur this is probably one of
those resurrected horses written by one
of the white walker generals but
probably not the night king because
remember
he would be riding the back of
resurrected viserion
in one more detail i just love the
subtle effect that composer ramin jawadi
worked into the music
raising the volume and intensity of this
reveal and then when it cuts to black
you can hear a different chord
reverberating creating this kind of
disharmonious offsetting feeling
so all this footage appears to be from
the first three episodes of the season i
imagine hbo is gonna be pretty cagey
about showing anything from the final
episode but
already a lot of these characters appear
to be in serious mortal danger so here's
my question for you which character do
you think will be the first
to die in the final season of game of
thrones comment down below with your
thoughts follow me on twitter and
instagram at eavos subscribe to this
channel check out my monthly live la
comedy show darkest timeline thank you
for watching guys i'm so excited to be
back
theorizing about game of thrones where
all the fans are so
appreciative and patient and
nice honeymoon's over
[Music]
you
[Music]